today's a new day we celebrate the
remarkable life and career of Jackie
Robinson before his number 42 was
retired throughout all of baseball
before he became an American legend
the Thor II stepped between the lines of
a baseball diamond for the first time
breaking the sports color barrier Jackie
Robinson had to do something all
ballplayers do before they can play the
game he had to sign his big league
contract the historic deal made him the
first black player in the majors and now
the contract Robinson signed with the
Brooklyn Dodgers could go on permanent
display the document is more than the
most valuable and important baseball
item that ever existed as Martin Luther
King jr. said I didn't start the Civil
Rights Movement Jackie Robinson did and
these documents are the founding
documents of the Civil Rights Movement
golden auctions began accepting bids for
the contract this week starting price
five million dollars but on Friday the
auction was postponed after an anonymous
party approached golden about buying the
contract outright with the stipulation
it would be displayed publicly whether
it's a corporation that uses it to
promote goodwill or whether it's a
museum or a foundation or somebody who
decides to purchase them and donate them
to a museum the contract was signed on
April 11 1947 four days before
Robinson's historic debut and it
guaranteed the Dodgers would pay him
$5,000 for the season appraisers say the
contract along with the deal Robinson
signed with the minor-league Montreal
Royals are valued at 36 million dollars
and you definitely have to give a
shout-out to general manager Dodgers
general manager Branch Rickey and a Ford
Frick the MLB commissioner ahead of
their times Branch Rickey called this
baseball's great experiment guess what
it worked it worked well I was I was I
was wondering what $5,000 which he was
paid in 1947 would be worth today
it's like fifty eight thousand dollars
that's it that's it
Wow ten percent of the sale price
goes to museums nice all right